it's a watershed moment for afghanistan
and for the western world with
breathtaking speed the taliban swept
across the country meeting little
resistance as they marched into kabul to
declare the dawn of the islamic emirate
of afghanistan
as armed fighters took control of the
streets of the capital thousands fled to
kabul airport in a desperate attempt to
flee the country resulting in chaos and
death on the runway
western countries are scrambling to
evacuate diplomats and local afghan
staff a humiliating debacle for an
alliance that had promised to bring
freedom and democracy to a land that is
known little bit war for more than 40
years
our title taliban victory a return to
terror
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to welcome our guests jessica berlin is
founder of co-struct a strategic
consultancy for sustainable business and
policy innovation she's worked for the
u.s government and for german
development cooperation in afghanistan
and says 20 years of war on terror in
afghanistan may have created more
terrorists than it defeated
and andrew gilmore is with us he heads
the peace building organization berghof
foundation which has been working to
promote dialogue between the different
parties in afghanistan he believes the
international community needs to talk
with the taliban and encourage positive
behavior a rejection of dialogue would
be counterproductive
and it's a great pleasure to welcome
once again ahmed wali
he's a colleague here at dw working in
the dhari pashtu department and he's
convinced the taliban are fighters they
will fail in nation building
so welcome to all of you and let me
begin uh wally with you you say the
taliban are fighters and many military
experts say that in fact over the years
they have dramatically improved their
strategic and operational skills
nonetheless is this breathtakingly rapid
takeover
more a fruit of their strength or the
government's weakness
i think both um
it is uh really a surprise that in that
speed they could uh overtake kabul uh
but uh it was something that was
possible and it was made possible in uh
2020 in february as the u.s made that
deal with taliban
not letting the afghan government a part
of that so
it is a surprise
but uh it is uh it could be seen um
that it will happen what conclusions do
you draw from the speed uh with which
the afghan army forces laid down their
arms what does that tell us
it tells us that the afghan soldiers the
policemen and all afghans are tired of
war they don't want war and especially
as
many of the um afghan soldiers think
that the taliban are not invaders they
are not outsiders so they saw no clue
why should they be fighting taliban
especially if uh
that they are earning 60 to 70 euros
monthly and uh they may have asked
themselves for what for a democracy that
is not a democracy and for the corrupt
um uh government so uh i think it was
their right to decide so and we should
respect that
and in fact those 60 to 70 euros they
were earning apparently were not even
always paid to them jessica the pictures
from kabul airport suggest that many
people are terrified by the taliban's
return to power on the other hand while
he was just talking about that war
weariness
does that mitigate people's apprehension
at all what are you hearing from people
friends colleagues in afghanistan right
now people are terrified there's no
other word for it i'm hearing every day
from friends and former colleagues on
the ground they're in hiding they don't
know what's going to happen to them
they're scared sick for each other and
for their families and above all with
kabul airport being effectively
surrounded by the taliban they're not
letting afghan nationals through people
are desperate and there's an increasing
sense of panic that the door is closing
and they won't be able to get out the
taliban's first priority though in kabul
has been to establish order to make sure
that the police phone line was working
to prevent
looting does that not raise any
expectation that uh they may moderate uh
their harsh behavior that we've known in
the past
in this moment no the fact that they've
taken a few videos of taliban fighters
stopping looters
is not changing the reality that people
remember what taliban rule was like and
right now they have no reason to believe
that this time around it'll be anything
different we've even just seen yesterday
dramatic images from jalalabad where
protesters went out in the streets to
raise the afghan national flag to take
down the taliban flag and what happened
there were shots fired several people
were killed they were being beaten and
even civilians in kabul just trying to
go to the airport have also been shot at
have been beaten so nobody is trusting
um the taliban statements that they are
they've turned over a new leaf
andrew gilmer your opening statement
said that the international community
does uh need to talk to
the taliban and of course uh certainly
the u.s did so wally mentioned the doha
agreement that the trump administration
signed
and that paved the way for what we're
seeing now many people would say
essentially the u.s giving away the
store
does that agreement contain any
provisions at all that could restrain
the taliban's behavior going forward
well yes it is
it does and i absolutely believe that it
is the job of all of us in in the
international community
and you you commented on the the
dialogue i mean i was 30 years in the un
and now with berkoff and in both this
organization it is founded on the
importance of dialogue with all parties
and we have a very intensive dialogue
with the taliban and have done for for
many years
and they make it's not just things that
that they've been sight that have signed
up to in the doha agreement but also in
formal agreements and i do think it is
incumbent on all of us to hold them to
their word and i think that's what we we
should be doing i think the the great
mistake would be to ostracize them i
mean the loss of credibility is so
dramatic on the part of the west i mean
your first question to wally was was it
the strength of the taliban or the
weakness of the um government and he
said both and i agree but actually the
real reason for the collapse was the
utter completeness and speed of the way
that they were deserted by their us
allies and that is what is the key and
why did they lay down their weapons the
real reason for that i think because i
was in i was posted in afghanistan in
the early 90s when kabul fell to the to
the mujahideen and for the first time
and a rather progressive society inside
kabul was suddenly um overcome and was
occupied by
very very non-progressive uh forces of
afghanistan in the mujahideen
and what one learned from that crucial
experience was that nobody is going to
be the last person to
to defend the government and what
najibullah had done in march 1992 was
partly at the instigation of the un was
to announce that he was going to leave
office and hand over power then to
actually not that many people surprised
including even his except that it was so
fast everybody changed side because who
wants to be the last person to be
defending um
particularly if you're
and get killed and to
then essentially um
be held and your family's
also held unless you can actually
change sides and that is what happened
if you if your great defenders have
signaled that they're going to desert
you they're going to change signs so
nobody should really have been surprised
by that once it once it was so clear how
comprehensively they were being deserted
i'd like to dig deeper on the degree to
which the taliban has actually changed
since that time since the mid
90s what do the taliban want this time
around and will the new islamic emirate
of afghanistan look like the old one
taking a selfie with the taliban some
afghans probably see the self-proclaimed
holy warriors as liberators from western
soldiers
after the taliban conquered the country
in the 1990s and declared at the islamic
emirate of afghanistan a 10-year reign
of terror followed until an
international coalition of troops led by
the u.s overthrew the terrorist regime
of islamists
now the taliban are attempting to
present themselves as more moderate
spokesmen have declared an end to the
war and are issuing promises that appear
to say exactly what afghans want to hear
peace and order for the country
the taliban are also negotiating with
all of the other countries that want to
impose their own power and security
interests within the region
among other things china is interested
in the country's raw materials while
iran like pakistan fears a new influx of
refugees and the west fears the export
of islamist terrorism
but
fundamentalists and moderates within the
taliban are waging an internal war for
power
where is afghanistan headed under the
taliban
and let me put that question straight
away to you wally the taliban are
talking about amnesties diversity
inclusiveness is there such a thing as
taliban 2.0 or is this a wolf that has
temporarily donned sheep's clothing as a
matter of expediency
well they are saying that and we have to
watch if they really
follow that what they are saying after
the takeover of kabul the taliban seem
to be conciliatory they have declared a
general amnesty nobody should be
prosecuted anymore men and women should
go to their work and offices and the
girls and boys should go back
school
with immediate effect according to the
taliban they want to form an inclusive
government as uh you say
that will be acceptable to the
international community and all afghans
but all these uh this should be done in
accordance with sharia according to them
what can be seen however is that their
fighters find it difficult um to react
in a conciliatory manner to
counter opinions and protests from
population
as
miss berlin said so the taliban have put
themselves a mission impossible
according to me state building is not
their specialty they are good fighters
some of them may be quran or islamic
scholars but building a state needs more
than only that jessica the taliban are
not monolithic what do we know about
divisions within their ranks and how
that could play out in terms of their
aims and their actions going forward
absolutely it's a very important point
the taliban is not a single unit
we tended over the last 20 years to call
anyone who was raising arms against isaf
against the nato military presence in
afghanistan
as taliban but it's much more
complicated than that afghanistan is a
patchwork of multiple different ethnic
groups who very frequently do not get
along with each other um also we're
dealing with a fighting force made up of
predominantly
undereducated even illiterate soldiers
who for the most part have known nothing
in their whole lives but war and poverty
so if you are trying to enforce a chain
of command from kabul from doha
to the soldier the talib in the street
with a gun who is being in a certain
moment
challenged by a civilian or confronted
with women doing something that in their
world view is against sharia and is
illegal and must be punished immediately
there's
that um that disconnect between the
harshness and the brutality of taliban
soldiers and what
taliban political spokespeople are
saying in kabul and press conferences
there's a huge gap between the two and
so it's an excellent point that was
raised earlier that we can't just
dismiss the taliban outright
we we certainly should not legitimize
this government but we do need to talk
and actually that's what we needed to do
20 years ago and failed to do and that's
part of what brought us to this
situation in the first place
andrew within that patchwork that
jessica just described is there a group
or a faction that might justifiably be
considered
amenable
to discussion with the west you said the
west needs to talk to the taliban do you
have such a group in mind no it's not so
much a group but there are certainly
individuals that we know of and are in
close contact with and i think but we
and i don't think we should be playing
um groups this is a good group this is a
bad group i mean i think also it'll be a
very self-fulfilling prophecy to say
talk about return to terror and it's
also self-fulfilling if if you assume
they're going to
massively discriminate against women and
return to amputations and stonings i
think we have to
in our dealings with them assume that
they have changed even if we have
obviously a little bit of doubt because
we cannot be certain and of course what
what is undeniable is that they are more
sophisticated and
the most clear-cut example of how they
are 2.0 um is that they are much more
sophisticated and they know what we want
to hear as well so we can't therefore be
absolutely sure that what we are hearing
is is the true picture but let us assume
that it is going to be and act as if we
assume that they are
acting in good faith and hopefully they
can be rewarded for behaving in a good
way rather than just being threatened
with punishment which is the gut
reaction so while he mentioned that the
new government is going to need to have
uh relations with the international
community not least for economic
reasons but does the west have any
leverage at all ever have after having
lost face and credibility with this
unbelievable debacle of withdrawal well
it's a very very good question linda of
course they've lost a phenomenal amount
of credibility that's why they have to
work all the harder i think i think they
need to really show the west needs to
show that they are have not entirely
deserted the human rights offenders who
have done so much to try to advance that
poor country in so many different ways
to stand by women educators and many
many other things and also to provide
generous humanitarian assistance plus
the fact that if we are generous with
asylum and of course we all know that
the political difficulties not least in
this country but
of of allowing refugees and asylum
seekers but that is also a form of
leverage if the taliban know that uh
western countries are going to be
generous in doing that they might be
less harsh themselves one of the big
difficulties though right now is that
the taliban does not want to let these
people out the educated class um that
upper upper middle class of educated
afghans who have been working with nato
who have been working
with international aid organizations
with the un institutions with the
embassies these are the people as wali
was mentioning who would actually be
able to run and implement a functioning
government and the taliban is acutely
aware that if they have a mass brain
drain events right now that the country
will fall apart and so um these people
are really being held between a rock and
a hard place um will the west stand up
for them will we find a way to bring our
people out into safety or will they back
to that in in just a moment absolutely
uh we're going to also look at the
situation of women uh and of course many
of
many women are amongst the educated
elite but let me first uh ask you wally
let's let's go back to the question of
the taliban's relations with the
international community if we can call
it a community and how that might
influence their behavior the fact is
back in the 90s the taliban did a
miserable job of providing jobs products
services it's one of the reasons uh for
their downfall at that time
obviously they're going to need help to
get the economy running to provide
development of any kind uh will that
moderate their behavior in any way who
are they going to be looking to
well i think the taliban themselves know
that
they can't run the state without foreign
aid without foreign development aid and
i think that can be a leverage
on the taliban that
one can talk to them and that
one can talk to them about the
what they should be doing or what they
should not be doing what they ought not
to do
another uh thing what
we know now is that the um the president
of afghanistan
he is an emirates and he has not
resigned and he has said yesterday that
he wants to return to kabul we have the
vice president in panchayat who has said
that he will be fighting and he says
after
ghani has left now he is the president
the rightful president of afghanistan
and the son of ahmed shah masood who was
the commander against the taliban a
resistant who was commanding the
resistance he is also
saying that he will not uh
give up the panchayat so that is also
something i think the taliban were not
expecting so
it is very important that the west and
every side should keep talking and the
dialogue
must go on it's very very important
let's talk about the uh every side that
wally just mentioned andrew because
if we look at the countries that have
been receiving taliban
leaders recently it's china it's iran
pakistan of course gave
great
support and shelter to the taliban all
these years
what kind of leverage if any would you
expect them to have over the taliban's
behavior going forward
well one thing we can be sure about and
a few other countries too
they are greatly enjoying what they're
seeing now because
the self-inflicted blow to our
credibility and the demonstration of
western weakness that has just been
shown so they're not going to do
anything of course as a favor to us
but on the other hand they don't want to
see particularly china i would say and
russia they don't want to see
a fundamentalist state
exporting
hardline
religious um extremism so they're going
to be they will on that front we can
probably count on them to to do the
right thing so the one thing that
definitely might change is that
afghanistan is not likely to once again
become a place that harbors terrorism
no i think i i would i think they'd be
too
uh we cannot be that sure of course we
need to be very very vigilant but but at
least those other countries will be
trying to
but equally those countries aren't the
ones that made it the base for terrorism
in the first place and let's also
remember that the way global terrorist
organizations work today is much
different than for
than 20 years ago
all right when we talk about a safe
harbor for terrorists uh
terrorism is also now a decentralized
global movement groups can coordinate
and collaborate and communicate with
digital technologies they're
decentralized networks so having a safe
haven quote unquote like osama bin laden
found in afghanistan in the 90s
this is not really the risk that we're
facing right now um if we're talking
about the risk of terror what i see here
is the desperation the poverty the
bloodshed the brutality because
terror grows where desperation grows
this is the problem and we have just
turned afghanistan into almost a more
miserable situation than it was in 20
years ago because we opened the door we
created this hope and this opportunity
for change
and now literally in the course of a day
it slammed shut i want to pick up on
that
the taliban claim that things will be
different this time saying that they
want to create an inclusive government
that won't threaten the west nor support
violence against women but girls and
women fear the freedoms and
opportunities that they gained over the
past 20 years will soon end
the taliban came to mosques and they
told everyone that their fighters will
marry off widows and young girls
they said that their fighters will marry
off two out of three daughters in every
family
we got scared and left
the taliban killed my husband and my son
four of my children and i fled the
fighting
we have been staying here since
yesterday evening we have nothing back
home
our home was bombed
i'm not afraid of them we are not the
people who will you know go back to the
dark era i'm a girl and i don't care
about anyone not pakistan not america
nobody else i'm here even today if they
kill me if they identify me i will not
care about them
[Music]
jessica the taliban say they will allow
girls to go to school they will allow
women to work within the bounds of
sharia law so very briefly if you would
what does that mean and what do we owe
to those women we've just heard from
whose hopes we have raised over the past
20 years
we have no reason to trust the taliban
to keep this word and under the laws of
sharia what is that supposed to mean
their interpretation of sharia will be
different from elsewhere in the muslim
world
the long and short of it is we cannot
trust them to protect the rights of
women and girls or of any men and boys
who wish to live freely and right now
the international community has one
responsibility especially all nato
member states who participated in this
mission we went in together we need to
leave together and we need to do
everything we can with the support of
the american military and the power of
the nato diplomatic community
to get our afghan staff and colleagues
and friends and the people who have
fought with us side by side whether as
journalists or interpreters to get them
out of the country
well the taliban have actually become
very savvy about digital communications
a taliban spokesman this week gave an
interview to a woman anchor whose face
was visible not necessarily something
you might have seen 20 years ago could
the this
new
media savviness exert an influence
also over the taliban's behavior in the
sense of pressure even via online social
media
what we have to differ is uh that what
is that the the things that the speaker
of taliban is telling and the facts the
fact is that their fighters many tens of
thousands they expect
their leaders to
apply sharia in afghanistan and if those
hopes are not fulfilled i think the
leaders will have a problem on the other
side the other afghans especially living
in the large cities as well as as well
as the international community expect
them to be moderate so uh it will be
very difficult for taliban
especially for the leaders uh to find a
midway which is acceptable for both
sides but one thing uh that uh most of
the afghans are united it is that all of
them are muslims and uh the other thing
is that the most afghans they don't want
war they are tied of war and they don't
want external intervention thank you i
think uh
yeah thank you very much i want to give
the last word to andrew the young girl
at the end of our report andrew made it
clear that she is ready to stand up for
her rights what would you say as an
expert on conflict mediation and
dialogue what would you say to the women
of of afghanistan today i would say that
look we are going to do
everything possible to to support you
and that is an incredibly important
message that we have to give to the
taliban as well that we are ready to
stand by the women and the human rights
defenders that is both morally correct
and politically expedient as well thank
you very much thanks to all of you for
being with us for this discussion and
thanks to all of you for joining in see
you soon
[Music]
you